the Joe Rogan experience ya know what
you were around when Pryor was in his
heyday oh yeah that must have been
something oh yeah we uh so you were you
were just kind of that was in 74 when
you were just getting there
prior with that was he was he was oh he
was already he was in the peak right big
time
oh yeah you know big time and um what
was that like it was he would uh you
know when I was around a communist or I
was basically the host of the comment
when I MCS you know and I go to the door
if they have a problem I go to the door
and settle the problem all this stuff
just Mitzi once she knew I'd do honest
up in it then wasn't no fighting and I'm
just being polite and stuff and Richard
would come in and look at the back of it
surprise in the back don't hear it on he
knew Paul Mooney Mooney was and David
banks all these in it anytime you got
all these guys in the comic store rich
you want to do another elbow so what
happened is Richard first time I saw
Richard in the bag I said [ __ ] are you
doing spoon I just come by to see how
you're doing I said fine I'm doing with
you never come out to see how I'm doing
he's just saying this to to set it up
for he wanna work on his act listen for
new album so I submitted everything fans
you want to drink nor smoke I'll be
finally one of those days no no just
come by and see how you doing how you
doing bit above about so imma go I know
to go away and come back and serve it
you buy anything you want to drink daily
wanna drink now see laundry he'd get up
some of the red drink he like waiting
all that cherry and it kind of stuff and
so I know to go away I go with they told
me in Michigan drive you crazy crazy
come back we're just gonna drive you
crazy so I I go away come back rich
everything a fan you know anything else
you wanted someone go Stacey knows yes
come on I say only oh hey hey Bahama
spoon real loud [ __ ] and so when I go
away and come back to Richard do two
minutes so people said Richard Pryor
came by the cop so he said sure I go up
didn't do to me he said whenever I go on
I see it going on right up this guy get
off you I put you on right now and he
grew up they do a 2 and a 2 hours
then his sin he'll call he'll have his
secretary called me the next day said
thanks for helping me get on stage
helping me girls day he knew he had to
be pushed on stage that's so weird
yeah that's amazing in it but rather
Williams me running Richard would do
like two hours without around a half
hour regular thing huh
who is album you know he got yeah then
he had his writers in the back morning
would bet they're writing him give him
coaching him on stuff to say you know
and stuff he had all that and then he
would have of three weeks in the
original room where he worked every
night he'd come every night Wow didn't
like some kind of you know get to hide
he can't come back he'll be better every
night and so Missy put me on the show
with him so I would open this show into
45 minutes and the [ __ ] would come up
to it I wouldn't have hmm and then we
moved to the main room after about three
of about a month in the original room
you moved to the main room that's one
man and he would draw so miss would make
so much money he would draw so many
[ __ ] people old holes ain't been out
on the street fur collars first coat of
fake fur coat on pink and yellow and
[ __ ] he would have in the main room he
would have oh my god
he had Mick Jagger what's the name -
born it uh it was his name Willie Nelson
I I thought Willie doesn't go up on the
stage and sing a song and there is in
the room really yeah really you got you
you good time yeah I got it
that's good you cook this sing a song I
love Willie Nelson he was so good he's
still around them maybe I'm scared to do
it I'm so nervous
he's [ __ ] people he went insane when
his son boy that was that wasn't that
was a thrill for me so then we move to
the main but now but I would kill every
night in the audience like that I'll get
a standing ovation because I would do
Mathis and I learned from Detroit and
Nat King Cole in him I would do Matt
Johnny Mathis at my last bit and I would
do L Greene just before that and
and I would I saw Al Green throw roses
out to the ladies one time how's that
yeah what is it
this theatre down anyway he would throw
roses he hands it to the ladies so I
when I was working at The Comedy Store
and I'm in front of it I would get down
the lines and handed from the ladies and
then lump-sum lady did exactly what I
wanted to say
she said Al Green give us roses I said
boy you lucky these ain't plastic or
dying got no damn money I go home and
watch to you so I can get back to you
and I did that doing dingy Johnny math
this is just impressions and I add it to
my act caused a lot of ladies out there
they love that [ __ ]
and I got it women through the Roses
back at my feet I said damn this [ __ ] is
cool in a [ __ ] and Richard told
me as a Richard everybody said [ __ ]
you should take spooning on the road
with you going on the tour you know I
love you spooning but you're too funny
angle I can't have you out there on the
road with me he said I was too funny for
him
Wow and he took finest you know finest
hit the shore the finest would do
impressive this day weren't all that
precious so he took him on a road he
told you you were too funny
swung you too funny I love you but you
too damn funny open for me
I don't want me were had to work that
damn hard that was a great compliment
but I have the the billboard of the
commie stolen richer crying John with a
spoon Wow I hey somebody my phone yeah
you you think mom posted it and then I I
think I repost I helped you repost it on
your IG story and then the Comedy Store
screenshot it and posted it yeah they
did that they do that like a month or
two ago his own TV show you know he's on
NBC at 8 o'clock and he was something I
boy I knew we were gonna last
that's it we only get four show they
were scared to 22
richer was too [ __ ] high what was he
high on cocaine in about good stuff
you know but I didn't had no money I
probably got me some if I had some money
hey I'm making this look for dollars for
the dollars that they give me for this
week he said yo y'all ain't making the
money but I'm making $250,000 show's
over damn
Wow he's making that much you know
Richard Pryor and John Witherspoon Wow
Jenni yeah I wish I had the year up
there probably 70 that's amazing 77 but
I know Richard please go his house every
Sunday please baby sounds every Sunday
and and he had he had a barbecue people
him look you got a gym boxing gym where
you box tennis court swimming pool he
heads for about four acres over there
and I realize it where was his own party
Nia yeah house there was for sale
recently for about four million but I
don't think people realize they're
[ __ ] prior living it they don't want
to do that called he be caught on fire
over there whoa
remember the time you got caught ya
knows that house it was in the house
there yeah [ __ ] I would love to own that
that's unlike Northridge or something
part thing yeah yeah it's it's on part
Dean and we doing more juice it's right
down the street don't feel yeah yeah
we're over every Sunday imagine owning
Richard Pryor's old house gotta cool
that spirit might hit me up five on run
past the swimming pool you know the he
don't came days must have been crazy
there oh man
and what's amazing about this is so cold
boy when stuff got on radio that Richard
Pryor is in hospital in critical
condition
he burned from burns from a pipe that
blew up his family went then stole all
of his his people that he probably never
seen in seen in years
jumped over that damn you had his huge
fence and stolen all his watches and
everything all this stuff take it out of
his house then they say he's gonna
survive they jump back over the fence to
put it back
what they jump back on the fence with
his stuff they put it back yeah they put
it back this Richard Pryor on steal his
stuff you even borrow from him for foot
20 years now I was saying you gonna
steal his watch
that's crazy yeah hard to believe we had
so much fun over there and Sammy Davis
jr. would come there every Sunday on a
limousine and a tuxedo on Kelly
we got shorts on you know your raggedy
short you can find old t-shirt we
playing basketball
send me come at the hi mine hi Sammy
put some [ __ ] shorts on was he back
then Sammy
yeah oh I bet he weaved this was 76 so
he must have been while he was young in
because he dad about 61 62 63 he must've
been in his 50s forties or fifties
tuxedo tuxedo and a limousine imagine me
in the wall but Sammy Davis jr. pulls up
in a tuxedo oh man a limousine we all
said it wasn't only basketball we also
[ __ ] uh we also [ __ ] raggedy stink
and we don't play ball Oh Sammy wrong
house one day I'm gonna play some ball
with a semi but we look at that look at
the bell-bottoms
oh yeah Wow [ __ ] to play tennis
Danny yeah you play tennis yeah and
basketball we playing ball [ __ ] he
checking me grabbing my dick funny man
[Applause]